listen if you're insecure which
everybody is let's be real you might as
well use the insecurity to get something
out of it one of my favorite things
about entrepreneurship is like use what
you've got and so a lot of people think
that they need to fix their conditions
in in order to get like the perfect
conditions before they start but the
perfect condition is whatever one you're
in because it gives you whatever assets
you have that's the cards that you're
dealt and so you just play the hand and
a lot of people have great cards it's
like man I'm so afraid of it's like use
it I have nothing it makes you very
dangerous because you have nothing to
lose